the White House is pushing back against
reports that President Trump dictated
misleading statement from his son the
White House press secretary says mr.
Trump was only trying to help his son
Donald Jr to up to create that statement
it was about his conversation with a
criminal connected lawyer during the
campaign the president Ernie has denied
the involvement which is spokesman
confirmed yesterday major Garrett is at
the White House
major good morning good morning
president Trump's lawyers say this
latest discrepancy is legally
meaningless perhaps but all involved
concede it is a political problem that
will serve to deepen the russia-related
suspicions this White House has tried so
energetically to erase he certainly
didn't dictate White House press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
acknowledged President Trump played a
role in framing the July 8th statement
in which his son Donald Trump jr.
inaccurately described a June 2016
meeting with the Russian lawyer the
statement that Don Jr issued is true
there's no inaccuracy in the statement
the president weighed in as any father
would based on the limited information
that he had the president's attorney Jay
Sekulow had no comment on that but the
White House Admission contradicted his
earlier claims that mr. Trump was not
involved
this was Donald Trump jr. and his
lawyers put together a statement sir
serving the interests of their clients
so I understand what they did and it was
not the president was not involved in
that Trump jr. statement said the
meeting with the Russians quote
primarily discussed a program about the
adoption of Russian children as he can
see from emails the pretext of the
meeting was hey we have information and
there was need of some small toys I
don't even remember what it was it just
was sort of nonsensical Indian and
garbled but Trump juniors email showed
the meeting occurred after politically
damaging information on Hillary Clinton
was offered South Carolina Republican
Lindsey Graham said misleading
statements only cause investigators so
if you want these investigations to come
to an end
the last thing you need to do is
reinforce the narrative if you're not
candid and honest about what happened
president Trump's son-in-law Jared
Kushner who also was at the meeting with
the Russian lawyer denied collusion with
the Russian saying the campaign was too
disorganized he joked with congressional
interns Monday saying we barely could
collude with our field offices in
different states the president's legal
team which has had its fair share of
turnover still trying to build a
cohesive approach with communication
about mr. Trump and White House
activities clearly Margaret there is
more work to do major thanks